الاسد بنيامين التنيو للمره السادسه يتزعم
السياسي المخضرم بنيامين نتنياهو رئاسه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه السابعه والثلاثين
والتي توصف بانها الاكثر يمينيه في تاريخ
الدوله العبريه حكومه نتنياهو نالت ثقه
الكنيست في تصويت حصلت فيه على 63 صوتا من
اصل 120 في الكنيست رئيس الوزراء الجديد
وقبل ان يؤدي اليمين الدستوريه حدد في
خطاب اولويات حكومته وسلطه الضوء على
اولويات الشركائه في الاتلاف دون تغيير
كبير في جوهر السياسه الخارجيه
5مار
للسكن
جهود ايران لتطوير البرنامج النووي الذي
يهددنا ويهدد العالم اجمع
سنواصل توسيع دائره السلام مع الدول
العربيه بهدف وضع حد النهائي لسراع العربي
الاسرائيلي
اتهموه بالضعف وبابرام اتفاقات وصفوها
بالمكلفه السياسيه مع شركه
[موسيقى]
احتجاجا على عودته الى السلطه وما
يعتبرونه افلاتا من العداله بسبب تهم
الفساد التي تلاحقها
اخشى ان يتم هدم ما بنيناه خلال اكثر من
سبعين عاما العلاقه الهجره التي نحاول
تحسينها مع سكان العرب في ظل التعايش
والاحترام لن تصمت طويلا مع حكومه
في ظل حكم نتنياهو توقفت عمليه السلام
الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه في تسعينيات القرن
الماضي في ما استمر توسيع المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه